sûre des poupons, des parents.
Jacaudrey Charbonneau.
- Raphaël n'est même pas encore
censé être né.
C'est un extrême prématuré.
- Les bébés peuvent survivre
à 24, 23 des fois. Mais tu sais,
en bas de ça... puis on ne sait
pas avec quelle qualité de vie
ils vont avoir aussi.
- Hospitalisée à partir
de 10 semaines de grossesse
à cause d'une condition rare,
Nathalie Nicolas a accouché
par césarienne d'urgence
à 25 semaines. Raphaël pesait
alors 600 grammes.
NATHALIE NICOLAS,
mère de Raphaël
- Moi j'ai ressentie ça comme
un échec parce que je me suis
dit : j'ai pas réussi à porter
la grossesse à terme. J'ai pas
réussi à donner tout ce que
je pouvais pour mon bébé.
C'est sur que que c'était
un coup dur, beaucoup
d'émotions, oui.
- Puis, vient l'impuissance face
à l'angoisse et l
de savoir s'il va s'en sortir.
- Moi, quand je suis rentré
la première fois que je suis
rentrée dans l'unité de
"néonat", la première fois que
je l'ai vu c'est : Oh mon dieu!
Il est attaché de partout.
C'est dur comme parent.- Mesure,
la pression sanguine, le rythme
cardiaque, les nouveau-nés
prématurés peuvent être branchés
à une dizaine de fils.
- Voici le système sans fils,
donc ce sont deux capteurs.
- C'est justement pour réduire
le stress, l'encombrement
et les risques d'infection
que des chercheurs de l'hôpital
pour enfants de Montréal
étudient actuellement
l'efficacité des premiers
moniteurs de signes vitaux
portables et intelligents.
- En plus de ça, vous allez
pouvoir avoir des renseignements
supplémentaires, par exemple
sur le mouvement du bébé.
- Avec un capteur sur la
poitrine, l'autre sur le pied,
les informations peuvent être
transmises à un moniteur
intelligent à l'extérieur de la
chambre, ce qui permettra aussi
de minimiser les sons.
DR. WASSAM SHALISHn
chercheur et néonatologiste
- La prochaine partie, c'est
vraiment de s'assurer que ça
peut se faire sécuritairemen
dans un système hospitalier,
où les erreurs ne peuvent pas
se permettre. Faut pas avoir par
exemple, un milieu où il n'y a
pas de r fil.
- L'autonomie des batteries peut
aller jusqu'à 24 h, les capteurs
intelligents pourraient donc
aussi permettre éventuellement
aux bébés de rentrer plus vite
à la maison.
PIERRE GFELLER, PDG du Centre
universitaire de santé McGill
- Parce qu'on pourra faire
la télémétrie et la
télésurveillance de ces bébés-
là, qui demeurent fragiles
pendant un bon bout de temps
plus rapidement à domicile.
Donc c'est un projet très
importan de qualité
de vie.
- C'est un peu pour cette raison
que Nathalie Nicolas a participé
à la première phase de l'étude.
- Ça ne sera jamais
lité, mais on peut
se rapprocher de la normalité
et ça, ça aide comme coeur
de parent.
- Même s'il faudra attendre
encore des années avant de voirs
large échelle.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.